as we bring in david spun who's now on
the north lawn of the white house
and david this might give us an idea in
terms of just how large this crowd is
can you hear any of the chanting and the
speakers
that they have set up in freedom plaza
faintly and we're only just a couple of
blocks away but there's also a lot of
construction
at the white house for the inauguration
reviewing stand for
president-elect biden and his family
that goes on every four years
regardless of what happens with the
election so you're hearing a lot of that
construction but
in the distance definitely can hear a
little bit of
faint uh excitement from that large
group
after all they're going to be leaving
freedom plaza and marching down to the
supreme court
that's going to be away from the white
house so we're not going to hear as much
of that
but leland president trump went through
that crowd earlier today
excited on his way to golf there's a
video of the president smiling giving
the thumbs up in the motorcade
as he passed by several staffers here at
the white house
retweeting and favoriting tweets about
this massive rally going on right now
in washington d.c some people calling it
the million
mega march but as i mentioned president
trump is golfing right now
at his club in northern virginia and at
this point there are still no plans to
concede no hint
of any concession uh leland yesterday he
came out
uh on camera in the rose garden to speak
for the first time in eight
days that is the longest time that we've
seen him since he's been president not
get in front of camera
and talked about operation warp speed
spurred by his administration the good
news he said that vaccines
will be available to the masses by april
now while talking about the vaccine he
singled out new york
and the state's governor andrew cuomo
listen here
he doesn't trust the fact that it's this
white house this administration
so we won't be delivering it to new york
until we have authorization to do so and
that pains me to say that this is a very
successful
amazing vaccine at 90 percent and more
but so the governor governor cuomo will
have to let us know when he's ready for
it
but governor cuomo and his team not just
taking it sitting down there
leticia james she's the attorney general
from new york she put out a statement
immediately following the president's
comments if dissemination of the vaccine
takes place in the twilight of a trump
administration
and the president wants to play games
with people's lives we will sue and we
will win
she also went on to say this is nothing
more than vindictive behavior by a lame
duck president
trying to extract vengeance on those who
oppose his politics
leland jillian the trump administration
continues to block a transition to the
incoming biden team
former white house chief of staff and
four-star marine general john kelly
out with a harsh statement that says the
president is putting the country in
danger because he's not allowing biden
to receive
classified briefings basically so he can
hit the ground running
the trump team continuing some legal
fights although some of those legal
fights are over in states like
pennsylvania
and arizona but even if president trump
does not concede
and general kelly said he doesn't have
to concede
it goes on life goes on and this
inauguration stand goes on
and the new president biden will be
inaugurated
on january 20th but we will see later if
president trump
does come by in his motorcade perhaps on
the way back from golf
uh boisterous crowd there of course they
will be probably closer to the supreme
court at that point but anything is
possible
so we may see the motorcade go by there
so
those folks are able to see president
trump and he's able to see
his supporters on a beautiful day here
in washington leland jillian
also keep an eye on the president's
twitter account this saturday afternoon
david thank you with